thank you to um the finance folks for
allowing us to use their room uh one
thing of note there is no heat coming
out of the
registers uh pipe has broken and we
doubt there will be much heat in this
building today um as we've experienced
in the last several days we have an old
old system and it's uh needing enough of
a total over overhaul according to Doug
downstairs so um with that I'd like to
get into and utilize our time before our
hands freeze up on us here um there's
been I just uh oh there was also another
sheet that I wanted to pass out to
you I don't know where that is we'll get
it
later
um sheets which I'm passed out you
should have there's a sheet that is the
old formula which we used in 2008 2017
with some updated information on
it there is a sheet which deals on the
top it says to from Jennifer Ford to
myself it has information regarding
teacher minimum salary teacher average
salary um um and uh principal salary by
school and lastly there was a sheet
which I got um I asked uh Rebecca uh fet
put together she's the director of
special education services over at uh
doe so it's a sheet with a little table
on the top
which reflects you know the weighted
value of special education in accordance
with the bill which we had last
year
and I had another sheet and I don't know
where I put it or where it is but if not
we can get a copy made again um this
sheet is the requirement of the federal
uh uh government doe and this is from
the Bureau of Education that we have
it talks about the categories that
school districts have to respond to in
terms of special education services um
for their reporting to the federal
government this is
Ida um indicator five education
environment school age and people in
policy have seen this before but yeah we
need to make some copies that if we
could
please unless I left to
somewhere
yeah thanks just a just a quick question
on the um the spreadsheet that M fet
prepared
MH it's got the child count it's got the
proposed funding which it was from the
bill we looked at last year right yes no
I I
just um those it's it's based on
count other words I'm talking about the
proposed funding per pupil th were those
the um the differentiated factors some
of those some of those values have
changed slightly here in accordance with
another sheet which we have so I we'll
we'll get in talk about this it's on the
all these are on the docket for a
discussion today um great thank you what
we got to do is that we have these four
bills in front of us uh one deals
strictly with swep the other one is the
foundation bill that you have and then
we have the two bills dealing with base
cost and the special education cost and
so we really really need to get into a
discussion as as a group right here
about those bills uh and and and deal
with them you know although two of them
are wrapped into the foundation
formula uh the
swep is is is an issue unto itself I
believe but uh so what I'd like to do
today when uh we we get back uh when um
Tracy gets back with that sheet these
copy I'd like to first get into the bill
which is dealing with the
$27,000 for a special education that
that one I think it's the last one that
was on the dock let's see yes is the
last one it's
1656 on today's agenda
here
very
much okay
okay nose would go
around
okay so the first bill which we're going
to deal with is the one that's on there
last at
1656 that's increasing the adequacy
grant for pupils receiving special
education
services and I think we all are familiar
with that um the it's simply raising the
additional uh area within the
differentiated Aid which we are
presently at $2,100 to
$27,000 per pupil um so what I
provided um is that there's a number of
sheets which uh I provided but there's
one dealing with Rebecca uh fet which is
the director and the sheet dealing with
individuals with disabilities Education
Act idea Part B indicator
five when we're looking at and
addressing the the students in these
categorical
areas just as a brief rundown we have
the 13 IEPs and we know that delivering
these Services uh are some of those IEPs
are much more expensive than another one
where students receiving a shorter
period of time the form that you see
from the data fact sheet which is what
we report in indicator 5 a b and c is uh
in accordance with a requirement that
the department has to collect this
information so we can break down the
IEPs by service time the amount of time
which they're engaged in receiving
Direct Services from special education
or indirect Services as well and what
Rebecca's done is she's breaking broken
it down into um a and there's two
categories within B which come together
the first one a is inside riger class
80% or more of the school day that's for
kindergarten through age 21 so they're
in the classroom the regular classroom
for 80% of the time the other 20% they
may be outside the classroom for
support in category B it's inside riger
class less than 40% of the day and
inside riger class 40% through 79% of
the day so those two were category put
together and so those would be students
which are uh receiving um a riger class
less than 40% inside riger class for um
the first one is when they're getting
only 20% this would be for everything
less than that and the third category C
is for those that are in hospital bound
residential facility separate School
Correctional Facility we're talking
about special education Aid and and CAD
a so what is being I asked um Rebecca to
give us this information based upon a
weighted Factor now this was in the
commission study as well and the
weighted Factor within the commission
study was
$27,000 per kid so 27,000 went to every
student who has an IEP regardless
whether they're receiving a half hour
instruction two times a week or they're
receiving five hours per
day per week in in which is much more
costly and some IEPs we know res require
certain services that are um contracted
services and very expensive and
Equipment as well and and and
specialized facilities within the
building even modifying
things
so
what I'm presenting is I want I'd like
to put this out for discussion here is
that I do not know based upon that and
this is one of the reasons why the vote
on the commission study was 16 to one
and I was the one I did not I did not
support the idea of funding the same
amount of money of 27 grand for every
student and and I'll talk the foundation
you can speak to that too but we that's
based off of and of course I'm an input
oriented person I want to know what
those elements are that are contributing
to base
adequacy that formula looked at the
opposite end and no matter how you you
you you move things around internally
you had to come up with that particular
pupil cost at the end or support that
pupil cost so if you had a weighted
version of in the formula which is 4.29
times the base and you change that to up
or down something else is going to have
to change as well within to get to that
final product and cost Factor so I I
would I I prefer myself to see us
support differentiated Aid in accordance
with the criteria that we have for the
categories and the criteria that we have
we tried IEPs before breaking the 13
IEPs down into separate categories but
kids cross over from one to the other
you have multiple handicaps and that's
not the way to do it and and after
contacting the department they have this
information in accordance with what the
federal requires so I'm advocating that
the formula that we propose be one if
we're going to make any changes to the
formula at all be reflective of a
weighted formula now just one other B
bit of information for you before we
charge off into the discussion there is
a sheet which we got from the education
Commission the states I had Jennifer 4
research the number of states which have
a weighted formula you can see it right
up top that you know it says the filter
for this on on the first page was
special education funding mechanism
multiple weights so they're filtering it
out to multiple weights and you can see
through there that there's a number of
states which do have this built into
their adequacy formula so we're going
down a path that we would be going down
a path that is is is well accepted
throughout the country and there's
others I have another sheet which I'm
not going to put that out in front of
you right now where there's hybrids to
this formula everybody is doing
something a little bit differ and how to
address this so what I'd like to do is
open this up to our discussion right now
and find out where people are in terms
of this this uh this
bill um and how it may impact um our
costing r ucation so it's open for a
discussion
1656 any feedback yes representative
casc cascaden she had her hand up to
ladies first sorry didn't see that sorry
no that's all right um maybe it's the
same question I don't know so 4.29 was
what we came up in the formula as the
weighted amount times the base comes out
to 27,000 So based on what you're saying
are you suggesting that that weight be
different for
an a a b or c category depending on how
much that service is yes yes okay yes
yes I am and and the
4.29 is what is it a c is it a b is it
an a 4.29 I don't remember is a weight
that's been given to all those
categories within that formula you're
talking about yeah and I'm I'm
suggesting that and I'm not necessarily
saying I'm support I'm not NE I'm not
supporting 4 .29 I think that's too high
so I'm
I'm the question I'm asking right now
should we develop
categories for for costing them out and
should that be reflective of the cost of
the base cost which is a result of
inputs y for what we see as an adequate
education so just it seems then it would
make sense for .29 to be highest or most
expensive Services right is that the
homebound or the out of District or the
the one that requires a higher level and
it doesn't it doesn't necess pay for all
the the the catastrophic Aid either it's
just what through what we're providing
for that student and the amount I
believe that comes out to not 4.29 if
you look at the highest category there
it's 1.29 of the base where are you
looking
that's the calculation I have here oh
yeah okay and in in uh the the other
where we now are
funding education around what $2,300
roughly right uh yeah y yep for per
pupil and that is a percentage of the
base right now so the percentage you're
seeing there is going to be roughly
around 043 of the
base and the other category in the
middle would be about 0.9 s and this
would be about 1.29 for the
catastrophic and the total cost for that
for the state the difference between
what funding right now differentiated
would be a little over 12 million2
million that's on the sheet that you
have
there representative luno you have a
question um yeah do um so the the 4.29
weight that we have in um in House Bill
1586 was calculated based on um on
actual costs that districts have that
are attributable to special education so
it's not a madeup number it's not a what
can we afford or anything like that it's
what districts are currently spending
that is attributable to special
education costs and it includes all the
category the three categories that
you're talking about I I agree it's a
it's a Blended a blended number all
special education cost
um and I and I absolutely agree with you
that that I think if we can get data
from the Department of Ed that we were
not able to get during the um during the
commission's work that breaks down costs
by category actual District costs
attributable special education by
category then then we can provide some
some um some better definition to th to
those differentiated Aid factors so I
absolutely agree with you um on that so
what I'm asking is um and this isn't on
the sheet I believe is what do we know
to be the district
costs attributable to special education
for each of these categories not not
just a a um proposed funding per pupil
because 1586 again separates costing
from
funding and and so starting with cost
what what what has the department been
able to provide for district costs of
special education attributable to each
of those
categories okay are there you know I I
I'm looking at we're basing it I'm
looking at the formula we have in place
right now and and when you look at that
formula that's how differentiate Aid was
developed off of the Bas the inputs and
what the cost of a teacher is what the
cost you know overall for um all those
categories what you see on the other
sheet that I passed out to you this one
yeah and on that sheet right there
notice that the the amount of money
which I put on that
sheet um is for
base was
$2,560 that is a Formula which been
derived based upon first year teachers
that are currently on the books right
now that's the average versus the the
original cost which was
$3,456 I believe but that was calculated
much the same way as this just this is
this is using the exact same formula
only plugging in and you can see if you
look at the bottom line on the back page
as you give the file that notice also on
this sheet right here the teacher K
through2 teacher has been reduced from
25 to1 to 20 to1 and the 3 through 12 is
reduced from 30 to1 to 1 to 25 but the
bottom line is it's
$485 as the univers veral cost of Base
cost okay so that's the figure we're
we're working off of to get to special
education right but how do we get to to
knowing what multiple or what weight off
that
4852 would be if we don't know what the
districts are act what their what the
district costs are for each of those
categories um you know the the the the
department has been able to give you the
the student count for each one they
probably have the
costs for
um for you know you know for those
categories of special education specific
special costs attributable to those
categories um of special education and
um I I I mean would doesn't that make
sense to have what what are you know
what what are the costs and then we can
come up with the
weights there is a bill that's in the
house right
now working towards forming a commission
to dig into exist what you're saying and
that you're the prime sponsor of that
rep we get that on Thursday and we're
talking about a topic here which is yes
you know the federal commitment they're
not doing what they said they initially
do it's what 40% they said they they're
cutting that down to 19% slow roughly
and so we're not receiving so what the
districts are going to have are having
to do through their property taxes
they're having to make that difference
up oh believe me I know that I mean we
all know that and and so the costing of
special education that's taken a huge
chunk of our operating monies for educ
so I guess what I'm asking Mr chair is
can we request the department to provide
the the the co the special education
costs attributable to each of the three
categories
Statewide um you know that that
districts are spending now and would
wouldn't wouldn't that help um not only
this subcommittee but also the of any
future study
committee represent can I add to that
request that the department um Define
the manner in which they'll collect that
data I think it's important that um we
start thinking now about a mechanism
because I think this is going to be a
have to do at some point um a mechanism
we know that um I don't know if they
call it i4c anymore whatever they call
it the student count yeah um is that
going to be the methodology and through
that process will that give us that
really accurate information that we're
looking for um so I just would like to
kind of know how do they think they
obtain that knowledge I I think to see
the actual cost the actual is very
worthy task okay um and necessary and
necessary as a sub committee though we
only have a week and a half two weeks to
get this thing done so I I think what we
need to do is that if we're all an
agreement that working towards a
differenti a component which is based on
categorical needs of these categories
and the only way I know of doing it is
in conjunction with that this this
requirement right here rather than
trying to find out by IEP I don't think
they have that information now they have
this information so what is the actual
cost for for these students get from doe
I I don't know if they they collect
that so so it's it's got to be somewhere
I know but uh that that's that's
contributing to the increase in our cost
for Education
totally so when it comes to this
particular
Bill how's how's this committee feeling
about waiting it all at
$27,000 that's what we're going to have
to make a decision up or down in that or
inter room study it or where are we
going I'm asking the question to the
commit M yep Mr chair the
$27,000 seems to be a number that is
attributable to special education
Blended across all
categories Mike my question you how'd
you come up with 4.29 four 4.29 was was
was was the total four 4.29 was done
through the air um uh report and they
looked at 10 years worth of doe 25 data
were able to pull out the costs that are
specific to special education divided
that up by the number of students and
came to a waiting factor of 4.29 off the
base of $6,500 but it's also related to
your end cost for a p puple cost in
education right but and it and it came
out to the 4.29 is roughly
$28,000 so so if another component
within this costing formula were to
change and go up would this have to come
down
um the so you you've got three
categories that you're proposing what I
and I'll just well in this but there's
other weighted components within form
right but you've got a low and a medium
and a high the high would be higher than
27,000 far fewer students
right the high would be higher the
medium would probably be a little bit
higher than than the the 27 and the low
would probably be less than the 27 if
you're actually looking at actual
costs on a per pupil basis for for the
students that are identified Statewide
in each of these three
categories I'm listening to you yeah I
mean that I'm I'm agreeing with with
your approach um Mr chair I think we
need to have get some actual cost
from the Department yeah I don't believe
we're going to have those actual costs
by February
15th I agree so then we're gonna have to
where because that is a component within
several of the bills yeah so you
know represent
Ames I just want to say that I
absolutely agree with doing this getting
those cost the 27,000 broken out into
these three categories and I think the
implication for this bill is that
uh if we think there's a kernel of
validity to it that it's it's got to be
put off into inter
study repr dry thank you yeah I agree
this is kind of a shotgun approach right
now and if we have the ability to Target
it better I think we should take
advantage of it and it may take time I
agree
yes I just want to speak on a very
conceptual
level um because I have no idea how the
$27,000 was derived let alone how it
would break out into three categories if
it was
recalculated but averages are very
dangerous especially if you have a broad
dispersion um and the fet chart reveals
very evidently what we pretty much
already know and that is that when you
break out into these three
categories there is no convergence in
the student count it's 22,000 Plus in
one category
2,000 uh nearly 4,000 in the
others so to try and average things that
are so widely
disparate um is a bad idea to begin with
and then the other
variable which is the uh the average
cost these
categories has the same problem so
mathematically you compound the problem
you if you come to a single
average that is derived from two
variables that each are actually very
disparate across the data
set which is to say I think the more you
break it out the more you differentiate
the better and so I think the three G
category approach is a good one yes
where we go in terms of getting the
numbers is well represent we're going to
have to get from doe and they're going
to have to get it out of the districts
yeah but we do have trends for a special
education in terms of uh the IE specific
IEPs going way back when I first arrived
that information was available you were
Deputy Commissioner at that time or a
little bit earlier than that but um the
trends are there and the number of
students for example in that last C the
more expensive category has been roughly
in the same ballpark um 600 700 students
and and then
um the total number of IEPs has not
really changed significantly it's
grown as we have our demographic going
down special ed IEP C population is
increasing and um but that is just
my quick look but I'm also seeing right
here a that's all the more reason to go
into into breaking out the categories
and and here they're using
28626 students for this it's it's been
higher than that and it's been up to 30
31,000 so we got to be consistent and so
there's going to have to be some
averages built in somewhere but
averaging it by these categories I think
it's much more efficient and effective
represent
Heath my mind um I know that U the
school fear fing has done an analysis of
Special Ed I don't know if it's okay to
ask Zach if he has any contributions to
this Con
conversation well if there are any
spreadsheets or any information that
people can give us I'd be very
interested in receiving that um uh
however and they're if they have
something they're willing to put their
hand up and we'll you know find out I
think what we will try to do is work
with the department and they often times
work with other groups as well and
gather gathering this information they
do okay
so
yes it seems to me uh if this
information is
available then you could build an
algorithm as part of the
bill and have the algorithm in the bill
but not the dollars and so if the
information can be had over time and
there something comes out the other side
based on the algorithm I think we're
even though I can't vote I think we're
agreeing it's better to have these three
categories
that's yes I agree I agree with that and
I think once if we broke out the
categories and decided what they were
because it's the goal is least
restrictive environment as you you see
in the data sheet right the the federal
indicators are already identified of 80%
40% and the last one so at least you
start with those three because you can
tie it to the indicators on Ida and then
like representative just said don't have
a dollar amount because it's going to
vary so much and then plug into a
formula each individual District cost
right you can see on the education
commission uh education Commission of
the states there that the information I
gave you there there there's several
states which have multiple multiple um I
categories for funding
IEPs
um I would think that to get that
information would be very very diff to
try to break it down that microscopic
may be very difficult given the nature
of the support we have At Doe and the
support that many of these small school
districts have which they don't
have um in a lot of these towns so this
sheet rate using these categorical
numbers categories that we know we have
to respond to these are being done and I
think that would expedite our whole
process and I think we would achieve if
we could have these three type of
categories we tried it the other way and
I had numerous special directors
contacting me saying this I and this IP
they're meshing together kids are have
both categories and you see this
movement on you you have students that
are are orthopedically handicapped or
physically handicap but also have a
disability and and or or or you know
maybe a traumatic brain injury and
so I think we better stick with what the
feds are asking us for yes um thank you
Mr chair I would um I just want to tag
on to what representative Ames was was
suggesting that uh that we we look at
interim study for 1656 so that we can
work on identify I think um
representative dry suggested this too
that this is going to take some time to
um to to you know understand and and and
put some uh put some numbers behind uh
behind this I was also wondering if um
if and I know it may be outside of the
specific scope of of this subcommittee
but if the subcommittee could also make
an advisory opinion on representative
Heath's Bill to actually study the um uh
the work because I think I think
supporting an interim study on this and
supporter supporting an OTP to actually
studying it are are very
consistent any comments on that has
everybody had an opportunity to read
that bill that you have there's one
angle in there you're also reflecting on
that we have to raise more
money and that equates to me property
taxes or income tax or sales
tax that's not the intent I can say
right right now out of the gate I will
not support income tax or sales tax and
I I that was in my report that Minority
Report that I put into the commission
study I think that's just going to be a
war on the house
floor yes yeah I I absolutely agree with
with with your comments um Mr chair and
and believe firmly believe if we're
going to do anything to try to address
school funding that we make addressing
school funding the um um the
the the the goal and not a not not
preced it with a tax debate and if we
can do so in a way that provides Equity
equity for students and taxpayers uh
without requiring getting into a tax
debate then I think we will have made
huge progress on this goal the purpose
of this committee we're dealing with
policy but we also have ways
and we have
Finance here with us and I think it's
important that we come forth with the
policy get that affirmed or supported
and then we figure out okay represent
Ames okay represent uh Tracy here figure
it out cost wise um thank
you okay but but we can't divorce that
topic though we can't divorce it that's
why we have people here right now with
us on this on this committee so
everything is sort of melded together
but we got to get our policy squared
away
first okay so I think that would take us
through that particular bill um is the
committee supportive of interim study
and also pending support we get from
that commission study as long as that
that committee study of yours represent
Heath as long as we don't get wrapped up
in income tax and sales
tax okay good yes further Mr chair for
the same reasons I would also suggest an
interim study on 1586 since it also has
the differentiated um um factors for
special education and should be brought
out into three categories and there's
that in addition to numerous other
um considerations that that would need
to be addressed in that bill that that
okay thank
you is that also agreed upon by the
committee here that then that we treat
uh
1656 and
1586 in the same manner that we would
support an interim
study yes can you clarify for me um in a
room study that just gives a window of
time to work out the details and does it
have a time limit or it's open well it
gets us right through the fall fall of
the Year okay I just try it's if there
are
these areas where we want actual costs
if we want algorithm um then I think we
need that time to do it
properly but I'm also concerned that we
are presenting we we need to get on it
seeing that we're going to be preparing
a budget for the next bayum very shortly
here and we need to know if we're going
to categorize something in
differentiated Aid whatever the cost
might be we'd have to figure that out
but we we need I strongly feel that we
need to categorize that differentiated
Aid
area is there any objection from
committee members on that point that we
need to categorize especially
Ed I agree yeah I think everybody's in
concurrence on that okay good represent
Heath did you have your hand up or
something no okay
good oh okay represent
dry to take good notes are we talking
about already interim studying
1586 yes we were doing both okay and my
my comment on that would be um is that
just to study the part with the funding
for special ed because I feel like there
are other well there are other areas
we're not we're not done yet here we
have two other bills here which we need
the the the base cost and we need to
talk sweat okay just I'm just want to
make sure that there are other issues
with 1586 don't get pushed away because
we're concentrating on the special all
we do is in this committee we're making
recommendations to the full committee
that will be made there understand that
and uh and if you go back to our task
which was put forth by the speaker
working with the minority leader we were
recommended changes in areas that you
know would benefit the children in the
state okay let's go on to the next one
then and I want to talk about the see we
got into one component there let's trip
over to the base cost one that's uh
1583 no excuse me yeah that's it yep
that's that's the base
cost um
help me out a little bit here the the
base cost we know is $4,100 right now um
that's based upon inputs right is is it
understood that this $10 million is also
going to be based upon
input or is this aligned with the other
other foundational
formula
Mr chair you're talking about
um
1583 yes correct yes um yeah my
understanding is is 1583 makes no other
changes um with respect to uh looking at
outcomes or accountability or anything
that it's it
would rely based on the the current
framework for okay okay input based
framework so then let's look at the this
the sheet right
here because this is doing exactly
that this is a sheet that was developed
originally back in 2008 through Senator
esbrook study when we had the costing
for an adequate education we also
developed what the opportunity for an
adequate education is and that was the
year I came into legislature so I was
really oblivious to what was going on I
was just in like a freshman in in high
school and a freshman in college um so
but the the the price back then was set
at at a much lower figure than we have
right
here and it was based upon all these
inputs that you see on the left hand
side teachers principal Administrative
Assistant guidance counselor library
media specialist and it goes to the
reverse side technology
coordinator and custodian and then those
other components which are not uh
instructional materials technology
teacher professional development
facilities operation and maintenance
transportation and came out with a total
cost for K through two and came out with
a total cost for grades three through 12
and then we came up with a universal
cost if it K through two there's three
three grade levels there we're talking
about that was multiplied times that uh
basic total cost 4K through two and then
they did the same thing for 3 through 12
they took that base cost of what it was
and multipli that by the remaining uh 10
because it' be grades uh 3 through 12
there's 10 there um and that was divided
by 13 because the 13 grade levels that
we have K through 12 and we came out
with the universal cost for base C
education so what this does I asked uh
the research upstairs to find out what
is the cost today for a firste teacher
is that correct
Jennifer you did it yes the doe has
information on the minimum first
teacher okay and you see that memo that
was handed out Mr chair yes the the
question I have though is that it says
if costing is based on a
208 to7 so are you saying that the cost
on this particular
sheet is the most recent cost it's not
based upon it's not on this is the if
you look at this sheet right here the
teacher minimum salary State average
minimum salary is
$425 that's the that's the price the
cost of which we're using right here in
this formula you look at the Top Line it
says 4256
Z on this
sheet that
sheet okay so we are using the current
information from doe here and then
there's a benefits package which 33% was
taken in account you had the total cost
which came out to 56
605 I did reduce that from 1 to 25 to 1
to
20 so that increase the
cost of of your bottom figure um but in
looking at the average per pupil teacher
ratio is much lower than 20 to1 I would
say closer to 14 or so there in that
ballpark that those decisions are often
times made by the local school
district and looking that I I've met
with some superintendent say that they
have to have a teacher and they have to
have a PA in every
classroom I was commenting earlier this
morning that when I was a principal and
later
administrator wonderful school over in
Rumford Maine West Peru where I had two
nuns one in kindergarten one in first
grade I could put 28 kids in that
classroom and they would all come out
learning how to basically spell and read
and everything else they were really on
top of it so these are local
decisions and so when they drop it that
low that's a local decision based upon
the characteristics of a community
whether it's poverty they may not have
the money or maybe they have some
situations where they need that type of
ratio um the state has to come up with
some kind of on an input basis what we
figure is the average input cost and so
using that salary that's how we came up
with it I did reduce it to 1 to 20
seeing that's more in common that that's
going in the direction that we it's
still above the average for the state
but it's going in the direction and and
dropping the high school also down to
one to 30 1 to 25 you can see grades 3
through 12 down to 1 to 25 we know that
in high school because of block
scheduling and all that there's some
classes they can load up a little bit
more than other classes and it should
balance
out so my concern is is that are we
looking to try to recommend something
that
is an increase or are we staying with
what we currently have on the books of
$4,100 per kit this would jump it
by to
4,852 in just some real quick
calculations that's over aund
million if you add in the special
education also so it comes up close to
115,000 115 million so there's there's a
jump
there it's open for a discussion I don't
want to poog it well yes represent
Ames as I think we all know uh
this costing
question um was the subject of a trial
um and uh in that trial to several
experts the superintendent that conell
was one of the principal
ones um walked through all these
different input cost so it was an input
based query that occurred at in the
trial and uh and out of that uh all of
which is documented in the Court's
decision uh came a 7,000 something
number uh $
7,356 per pup number which is higher
than this uh know I I can only talk
generally about this but uh but that
analysis is here is a different analysis
than the one you that was worked through
what was it 19 uh
200 uh8 I think
um and
uh it basically found that it's more
costly to run schools than
is shown in in that data um I think we
have to deal with that not just work
back and try to work over and update the
analysis that was done 12 years ago
whatever it was now remember there was a
sheet passed out at the last meeting and
if we took the all the state
appropriation dollars which are going to
these
districts the current law
adequacy on average in the state is
$682 per
pupil that's what it is now that's
pretty close that court
case representative Miler yeah I think
to tag on to representative ames's
comment I think it's important because
from what I understand in the courts in
the court case the state had no
justification for the current
4100 there was they made no no apparent
Appeal on why that figure is
good uh the uh defendants the state
basically try to
nitpick what the input model that was
coming forth from conval and so I think
as we begin to look at the 4100 moving
it to 5100 to 6 th there's got to be a a
better basis which what I think the cour
was saying is that there's basis for the
need to increase that figure and that
the current process of what we're doing
is really what they were ruling against
as it relates to where we are right now
in the funding them I don't think
they're against
input I I I agree with you on that I'm
just saying that the current way that
the state is funding has no merit was
was was not there was no
justification on the part of the state
appeal that the current way we are
funding it 4100 has any basis whatsoever
so I'm not a lawyer I don't want to get
in talking about what's happening in the
blinsky case or the conell case and all
that we're here today to try to address
this side right here
and we have not looked at the costing
formula that we have on the books dve
back
2008 looked at in 2017
2018 in conjunction with are these
inputs what we want are these inputs
what
are uh needed out in the in the schools
um and yes there are a lot of nontan
non-tangible things which are going on
in schools that are not going to be
controlled by
money and that's and I mentioned it
before the aspiration of the community
the the parent involvement the
leadership in the building the quality
of staff and the staff's teaching and
and have the curriculum and instruction
aligned with what the state standards
are all those types of things and more
come into play and those are things
which vary from District to district and
some District costs are higher and lower
than others yes and maybe that's due to
the property equal property valuation
and it may be also a result of these
these variables which I just mentioned
and more there's more
variables
so I I I
don't I I think for example when I asked
a question to the conval folks we need
two adults in every classroom teacher
and a parah that was it I said what
happens if it's 10 10 to one we need two
well that's the state's not going to
support that it can't support that so I
I think what we need to do is really
need to take a look at what is going to
be our base C this is what we have this
is current law and we're dealing with
current law right now if the interum
study comes out and goes some other
course fine but are we going to say we
looked at this as a subcommittee and we
think it's fine the way it is $4,100
does the
job
representes I guess what I would say is
that I think this is an incredibly
complicated inquiry we all know that I
mean that's saying nothing we all know
that but it's incredibly complicated and
to think that we're going to be able to
sort it out in this
subcommittee with the two weeks or so
left to our to our uh existence uh is is
foolish we just can't do that so it it
seems to me that uh that this
points towards what we've already said
about uh what is it
1586 um and uh interim study that this
this question is really a subset of the
questions we were talking about special
education and how that might be divvied
up in a different way and looked at um
and uh 1586 itself has the whole you
know whole picture there um why
shouldn't this be part of that uh
instead of dealing with it
separately I don't want to go with the
assumption that that 1586 is going to be
what we're working towards um we we look
at it I didn't mean to imply that I'm
sorry yeah we we want to we're looking
at that basic charge we had for the
committee
um
this group will have additional
discussion to evaluate the successes and
shortcomings of the funding formula for
kindergarten through grade 12 and
propose any changes to improve the
funding formula and they may obtain
technical support or input as needed
that was in this charge that would came
out from speaker's office uh
so while we're looking at this do we see
that there's a need to look at the
current formula in terms of how we are
coming up with the cost costing amount
for base
cost represent
cascad thank you
um I'm
struggling in hopes that we are not
Beering off the work of the commission
because it's so technical this work is
difficult um and we spent a whole
year grasping with trying to summarize
everything that we learned in the
costing out of an adequate
education and in the end the
recommendations were that we felt
Transportation should be
included and I don't recall at this
point um on the school health the school
nurse position because it's not listed
in here but I don't remember the outcome
of that one um but why would we not
start with the summary or recommendation
of that
commission and move it forward in some
fashion because the outcome was not a
specific dollar because every single
district is different in size different
in
expense and if you put in
certain you know factors right we had
that
conversation
um why aren't we moving from that to
move the needle
versus in can air develop that algorithm
that representative AR was kind of
playing around
with I mean if this committee feels that
that's the
direction now you're talking to Rick lad
I am and Rick lad was the one who voted
against the commission report but you
said it was because of there's good
things within it there good things
within it right right but I I I do not
comprehend or understand how you came up
with that
the figure you're you're deciding this
is what we got a fund education at at to
maintain or get get to that achievement
level we want these kids at what are the
inputs for that end item and what are
and where did you get this end item
based upon what the doe 25 form didn't
we identify that the commission was
transportation's taken out of that but
that Doe 25 form has all your expenses
all of expenses are all those expenses
adequacy right I don't know I don't
think they are represent Luna yeah th
thanks um Mr chair and that's one of the
things that I'd suggest we take a take a
look at in interim study on that because
um because I I do agree with you that
that I think I mean obviously I'm I I I
really feel the an outcom driven
um definition is strong but I think also
having a a hard deck establishing a hard
deck as far as the um the um the core
components of an adequate
education as they exist right now in one
1932a having that those things listed I
think makes a lot of sense too uh so so
I I'd like to push that to an interm
study thing but going back to the bill
we're on right now
1583 right yeah 1583 um I guess I still
don't
understand
where conval differs from from this you
know the modified
2017 uh chart where you've updated the
um the the salary the benefits and the
um the teacher to student ratios and I
was wondering if maybe um um um U Mr
Sheen uh might be able to talk to us
about what the Court's actual well we
had this sheet which was provided to us
by our research upstairs M if you dig
down in it you can see the teacher
minimum salary in public disc school
districts 20232 24 4256 you can look
exactly and find out what C conal's
minimum salary is where they where
they're starting and where are they well
you have to look down through here um
this has
combat Oh you mean actual what the conal
district yeah yeah oh I I was more more
interested in what the conal court um oh
okay I thought you talking about the no
no and I mean just to just to understand
because representative Ames
representative Myer talked about what
the what the what the how the court
developed its its
7356 uniform cost and I was wondering if
Mr uh Sheen might be able to but I'm not
interested in in the court no no I'm
interested in the legislature doing this
I'm just I'm just trying to understand
what the court
did with elder respect Mr chair I think
we are trying to make informed decisions
and everything that we need I think the
court essentially is part of the work
that we need to do and we need to be as
informed as much as we can so I kind of
agree with u representative luno and I I
would like to hear from from Zach in
terms of our thinking um in terms of
what the base should be we grappled with
it in division
two representative didn't we um and or
grappling grappling absolutely and there
were a lot of factors that that we had
to consider and that bottom line always
kept coming up but I think what happened
in the courts has to influence they're
expecting the legislature to to respond
somehow so I would vote if I could um to
hear what um uh Mr Sheen has to
say we've had input from various groups
last several meetings we've had I think
it's time for us
to if we we've all discussed the idea of
inim study and looking through the bill
that you have representative Heath yeah
uh I I think it's time for this
committee to decide side you know some
of these issues without saying well
we're going to need another darn
committee the last commission study we
had was a half a million dollar
commission and we came out and we have
flaws in the report or misunderstandings
or people that don't I don't understand
all of it in terms of where they came up
with that goal the performance
outcome and uh based upon what what
criteria we are tasked by the statute or
by the the court
to
identify regardless of poverty or wealth
of a district to provide an adequate
education fairly to all kids and that
means costing it out yeah and and and it
has to be done I Believe by inputs and I
think this is where we're coming down to
it that there's some that believe this
performance outcome side
without and I think it's going to end up
you're going to have to deal with the
inputs there too but there's another
side in this house that are saying we
like the input method because we feel
we're meeting the requirements of the
court
cases now whether we're costing it is
another
issue well you got two hands of rep ases
and then Ways and
Means Ways and Means comes before
education okay um well um as I said
before I think interm study is going to
be needed and uh as I also said it's a
complex inquiry and U so um before
moving on from that thought um interim
study has to be a real interim study not
just a a way of deferring action on the
bill and then killing it um we need to
this is a good good way to look at it
we've got people from finance and Ways
and Means and education and uh the
leaders are the education committee
people it's it's got a good structure to
it in my opinion um and we need to look
at both ways of looking at this as
costing this out the outcome based model
that leads to certain things and the
input based approach that uh has led to
slightly different numbers or different
numbers um we need to go through that
and if in the end um the committee
assigned that function of uh
studying uh comes out with a couple of
different options so be it that's okay
the legislature in the end is going to
have to look at this thing so that would
be maybe in my my view a very good
outcome if if um the committee has two
ideas about how to solve this problem
let's put them on the table and then uh
the larger group that's the legislature
can try to figure that out
um so
uh in all by all means build on the work
that's been done in the past take into
account the court and what it has tried
to do in good faith both sides that
worked in good faith on this struggling
with uh with a very difficult issue this
P you know plagued us troubled us for 30
years uh let's see what we can do by uh
by this
approach by just that approach or
see I myself not interested in getting
involved if it's going to be just going
in and doing exactly what happened in
the last year where the commission
report that's all we were looking at one
model we had decided this is the model
we're going to do it there's another
model which was done in 2008 and again
in 20171
so I think if there's going to be
something about be looking at the whole
issue of costing an adequate
education and we ought to be open and
not just going down One
path represent Mila thank you I want to
just pick up on what represent am said
it's been 30
years 30 years since the first clont
one since that time we've had four or
five cases
again and each time the Supreme Court
has said to this legislature fix it and
each time we've walked away from it
we've tinkered with it we've added a
little bit here a little bit there but
we've never really met the Mandate of
the Court this court for the first time
put a marker
down they put a marker down of
$77,000 of which he said is a consern
conservative figure should probably be
more so it seems to me that we are at a
we are at a pivotal point in time
here where whether you like the judges
ruling or not to me is
irrelevant because it's going to go to
the Supreme Court and frankly the
Supreme Court's going to say the same
thing fix
it so I think it's incumbent upon this
group and the legislature to finally
after after 30
years to come up with a formula whether
it's input formula whether it's output
formula you know where I am on that my
concern is
equity we've never really looked at the
issue of equity other than a little more
money for this district and a little
more money for that District that hasn't
met the need so my hope Mr chairman is
that somewhere between now and the end
of this legislative session we will
finally be begin to take our
responsibility to fix this for all the
kids in this
state you want me to re react to that
um I I the sheet that I have here this
spreadsheet right here which was
provided to us several weeks ago current
law adequacy Aid per pupil in this state
FY 2025 6,82 $ 5 we're close we're
close and so so so to say fix it I I
think that the legislature has the
responsibility to cost this education
and I will also agree with you there's
areas which have not been updated that
need to be updated but it doesn't mean
that that whole formula which was
established and and and and discussed
again later in
17 that it's not able to do the job we
have certainly tinkered with this
formula over the years around the edge
and taken probably some of the good
things out of what we had in 2008 that
are no longer there we we we took and
and made put a stabilization component
in 150 something million dollars in
stabilization to make the formula work
that was not needed in the 2008 model if
you look carefully at it the hold
harmless within that model was around 20
something million dollar total 2427
million somewhere in that neighborhood
and we had a formula that was there the
augen same thing if we had funded it
properly we probably wouldn't be here
today so so you know I I I'm not saying
that you know I'm not trying to say that
the whole formula is broken I don't
think we've taken the time properly in
the interim to reflect upon the changes
that are going on in our inflationary
Society uh that we living in and all
that to make sure that we're we're
meeting some of the wages that a teacher
requires to be Survivor and have housing
Etc um I couldn't do it on on $4,100 you
know whatever we're doing in here yet
that's there's a lot of local
responsibility in here too where I can
look on that sheet where it talks what
are the beginning salaries you can look
at Handover someplace and it's huge they
have the ability to pay for that whereas
others are $40,000 for that starting
teacher or even less
yes thank you Mr chair I respectfully
disagree with you I do think the current
funding formula is broken uh I think
courts have said that but I haven't come
to that conclusion because of what the
courts uh are saying I'm I'll just refer
to what you just you know sort of held
up right right here and I'll I'll pick
out a few um um a few ones that can sort
of jump off easily the uh current law
adequacy Aid per pupil fiscal year 2025
right from that sheet look at Jackson
$3,929 per pupil go right before it
Hudson $
4,9 $61 per pupil so Jackson gets nearly
twice the adequacy aid that that Hudson
gets go down to the bottom of that page
towards the bottom Newcastle
$41,000 uh
$41,900 per pupil in state adequacy aid
go right above it to Newbury
$1,450 per student adequacy go right
above that to New Boston now we're
talking about small towns for
$4,700 per student inadequacy Aid if
people think that's not broken that that
that is completely illogical to uh to
have a um to have a funding system that
that that I mean talk about spread or or
you know disperate spread which is what
what represent spilburg was talking
about this this shouldn't be anywhere
near what we're what we're seeing here
the formula is broken the funding
commission concluded that the formula
was broken they said it was broken not
just for taxpayers but for students too
and how can it not be broken for
students when the students are being
funded by the state at nearly
$42,000 per student in Newcastle and in
in um in New Durham at $5,100 per
student how could it not be broken in
terms of student outcomes and I know
you're not an outcome base guy you're an
input based guy but I think there's room
here to look at both and my background's
engineering Rick you know that not
education so so you know I've been
involved with probably more you know
tech companies than I than I care to
talk about but in in all of that that
experience we looked at both in about
both inputs and outcomes when when when
building products and I'm not trying to
equate students with widgets or anything
like that but you have quality assurance
to make sure that what goes into the
system is is is is correct um that's the
that's an input driven thing and then
you have quality control does the
product perform you know ultimately
that's what happens I mean you can you
hopefully when when we when when we
build cars and aircraft
we look at both of those things not
saying well you know we put the right
parts in it should work great you test
both and um and
so I think there's there's a lot of room
both on the formula and on the
approach I'm not just input person I
think accountability is very very
important and performance outcome is
very important and I believe our current
statutory language references
performance and out outcomes if you look
at the 2008
Formula and if we had that formula in
place today which had fiscal capacity
disparity Aid based upon medium family
incomes and property valuation if we had
a differentiate Aid component in free
and reduced lunch where that money was
allocated out based upon a weighted
formula it had the waterfall effects in
it representative Heath and we that's
not the way to do it it needs to be a a
slide if we funded in accordance with
that formula where would we be today
does anybody know I would I would bet
that we'd be a lot closer to where you
want to be if we were to follow what
Senator esbrook and Company did and I
know my party back then would was in a
minority on that but that's where we are
and we've come I've come to appreciate
that formula I don't think it's
something we need to throw away in the
trash can and say it's not it has no
potential potential for work we have
chipped away at it in 2011 we murdered
it and now here we
are so I think that in any look we need
to be open to looking at everything we
can to ensure we get the best for this
state agree agree okay I yeah I I think
we're I I from for one absolutely agree
with what you just said we need to take
a a a a look Square on at that original
formula in uh in
2008 and see where that takes us we need
to look at this Foundation opportunity
budget Formula 2 and we need to uh come
to some judgment as to what's the better
way to go you know it's as simple as
that but it's complicated okay I think
we've you know hammered on this one bill
that which is the base cost let's let's
get to the the swep
bill um
we it sounds like everything we want to
study but you know I'm I'm a little
concerned that from a policy perspective
in the committee I don't know if we
have I think there are some changes
which we could make just recognizing
that a a 1 to 30 a one to 25 this is a
recommendation I made back in the
20178 18 study represent mil you were on
that and I talked about the pupil
teacher ratio and how that needs to be
looked at we haven't looked at it
seriously I think we need to look at
that now and regardless of where we go
in the future we need to reflect that in
our costing out an adequate education so
in the policy committee I'll be really
pushing
for for some change to reflect you know
get closer to where we want to get
whether that's the way to do it maybe
maybe some study will figure that out
but rep some M your red lights on well
well I was going to just say I mean you
and I both
co-sponsored the bill that created the U
2018 study and my position was what your
position was on the commission I did not
support the recommendation out the 2018
I thought I thought represent umberger
did a a very good job in bringing forth
material which we didn't have a chance
to really look at and evaluate that's
why then I introduced the bill for the
the uh commission to look at it in 2020
for the very reason that I didn't think
that the 2018 had time to look at it and
I think that the 2020 did did have a
chance to look at it and there's
substance in there to try to bring both
components together to try to see how we
can deal with not only the fair funding
of it but also I'm going to go back to
the issue of where's the equity I'm I I
want to for me my bias is I want to have
the program student centered not things
centered because I think we missed the
opportunity to look to see how the
formula can impact student performance
rather than just trying to to look at
this widget and that widget and this is
how much it cost that's my bias but I I
I would concur with with representative
Ames I want to look at both of them to
see if we can find some way with which
we can deal with the the concept of the
input but also figure out how perhaps
that input model can then be more
student focused to make sure that
there's Equity so that kids across this
the state have some sense of equal
opportunity because we know they don't
have equal opportunity right now based
upon the structure the formula that we
currently
have okay yeah we're from policy and
policy has a lot of discussion going on
and and what we got to do is we got to
move on to the other bill right now
um
okay those people are on the
subcommittee here how are you seeing
1583 1583 is the bill dealing with the
base cost of 10 10
grand do that should that be an inun
study or or can this bill be amended to
reflect a a base cost which would
influence those people designing the
budget which would be coming up in
another
year
um um so do we want to jump start a
little bit or or you on them not saying
that's the end product but do we
recognize there are some holes and do we
want to amend something but doesn't that
but doesn't that one also blend in with
the conversation in general with where
where we might want to go I mean to just
to take that in isolation with the other
conversation we've had this morning
seems to be antithetical to the idea of
trying to look at the various options
because clearly is one of them there's
no question about that uh but I don't
think we're going to have time this
particular
Bill isn't mentioned at all in the
foundation formula no $10 million it's
separate the other one 27 is a direct
result of the 4.29 weighted factor and
the foundation bill
is with that but this right here is kind
of like a separate bill talking about
base cost do we want to are we satisfied
that the base costs then remain at
$4,100 are we satisfied that the pupil
teacher ratio remain 1 to3 and 1 to 25
can we make some simple suggestions
through this bill and use as a a bill to
go forward
to to address those issues so represent
cascad she had her hand up um my opinion
is that we don't act on this bill by
itself because I feel history is going
to repeat itself we're going to come out
with another number it's not going to be
10 might be five who knows what it's
going to be and we're going to agree to
that then it's kicking the can down the
road again and we haven't resolved the
situation so can't we include this bill
in the interim study because we talked
about
1586 includes the whole package and
there's a lot of parts to
it but I don't think we should isolate
this particular bill but this there's no
inputs like this in the foundation
budget or a foundation package are
there I didn't see that it was all the
outcome right so so this is a compromise
in the interim
study just my thought to move are there
any other thoughts from the rest of the
committee here you know representa luno
yeah thank you Mr chair
um so
so notwithstanding inputs and outcomes
um and just looking at at
1583 when you and and Mr chair you you
and I certainly worked hard together col
collaboratively during the budget
process in looking at at the the uniform
base cost as well as the differentiated
Aid factors and you talked about the
current budget we're in right now
current budget that we're in right now
we talked about 400 4,300 400 absolutely
and and you know the current budget
we're in right now has a costing formula
that is very much looks like what's in
in 1586 too I mean it's a base cost and
then differentiated factors albe at the
numbers are different but but what when
you when you just look at at turning the
dial on the base
cost let's let's let's look at Berlin so
I'm looking at that you know what what
you had passed out last week looking at
Berlin so turning the dial on the base
cost from 4100 to
9479 I think is what uh the department
modeled here
Berlin's um
uh average student aid goes from
$122,000 to 13 well $
12,289 to
$3,876 it doesn't really move that that
that all that much it goes from what to
what 12 12,000
$1,289 to
$3,876 um where and and and let me just
sort of look up to um
to Bedford um bedford's nearly
doubles so I I'm just be
because because our funding formula is
so out of whack at at this point when
you turn a dial with just one number and
you think you're going to do a good job
for Claremont and Berlin and Pittsfield
and all the the towns that that that are
really and Manchester that are really
struggling when you turn just that one
dial of
uniform Universal and and Rochester
absolutely um it it it doesn't actually
put the State dollars where you
think you you want you want them to go
and the the the
Department's the department spreadsheet
she on this bears that out so so I I
think that's a good reason for interim
study so that this bill can be looked at
along with the other it's not it's not
kicking the can down the
road to interim study this because I
think just increasing that number
doesn't doesn't address the school
funding um problems that that that we've
got it's more complicated than that and
it's more complic ated than what this
bill does and it's more complicated than
what the conval Su I I would like to
speak to that point because in finance
we turned a
dial and yeah and what happened was we I
think appropriated 150 million dollars
additional for all of the special
requirements once the crank got turned
on that it didn't move the needle hardly
at all because 80% of those funds went
to NASA Manchester and con
and nothing to Berlin I mean the towns
that don't have the tax base didn't
benefit so and I'm just bringing this
out because whatever the formula is
we've never even talked about that in
this committee so far that was a big
issue as we felt well you know our towns
are doing fine those towns aren't let's
put some more money in it didn't do a
thing so that Crank that had the
stabilization built into it I called it
the thumb on the scale the stabilization
process seemed to
normalize I'll give with a small end the
disparities but that's why you have some
towns getting 15,000 student and others
getting eight but that was the thumb on
the scale in the back room I don't know
if you can formulize that that's that's
I've
been upset about that ever since we
passed the budget is how do we fix it
because we we were sitting in this room
we couldn't even understand all of the
issues and it's like and I don't think
we're stupid people but we just couldn't
comprehend all of the complexity so I
can tell you as moveing the
dial
zipo so there is there is a something
else going
onair just in response to what
representative ammer was talking about I
absolutely agree that and and and I
applaud the budget process the work that
was done and looking at moving several
dials as as you did um um but you're
right it didn't accomplish everything
that we thought and that it that it that
it should accomplish um and I and I know
we're thinking you know interim study on
1586 and I absolutely think that that
makes a lot of sense but 1586 does move
a lot of dials and and my understanding
is that Mr manelo from the Department is
going to be here this afternoon with
some spreadsheets whether we're going to
be look look my understanding is that he
is oh he is I see the head going up and
down yeah I talked to Mark yesterday
yeah and and and so so and and I'm I'm
not I I haven't even seen the
spreadsheets I know he's running a bunch
of different models on he done he had
them done last night by four o' but but
what I'm what I'm saying is we we you
don't even need to like look at the
numbers and say well this is too much in
total or too little in total I'm not
even I don't even want to argue that but
but you can you can see from looking at
that that that that it it it does a much
better job to to pushing State dollars
where they're needed most and and um and
and so you know thinking places like
Manchester you know and and even with
all the money that that the the
additional dollars that that got pushed
to Manchester um you know um chairman
par was I think quoted in I don't know
where I read it over over over the last
week um that that you know we're we're
still our our budget is still $50
million short of just being
average average per pup uh cost and that
that's that's not even factoring in all
of the extenuating challenges that uh
that the city of Manchester has with
regards to their population so so I'm
just saying that that that we that there
are that when when when when looking at
the frustration that we have with the
current formula and turning the limited
dials that we've got there that there
may be better approaches to it and I
Know It Takes it's a it's a big bill
there's a lot to there's a lot of
changes that would still need to be
considered as represent dry um talked
about last week as well as this morning
absolutely agree with that
um but uh but as far as a model you can
sort of see how how you know maybe
there's something we could do that does
a better job than represent
Kad just to add to that a little bit
then I go back to the commission it was
such hard work over an entire
year for the representatives that
weren't part of that commission we ended
up having um research company develop a
simulator tool for the very reason that
we recognize that diff different size of
districts different expenses are going
to vary all over the state it's you know
far from being uniform and the needs are
different and this particular simulator
tool would allow us to take individual
New Hampshire districts and plug in all
of the
variables and it would I'm not a math
person crank it out and then it would
pull it
out and it seemed like it it fed and so
I don't want to throw that whole
development out the door to get to where
we want to head head to so I just wanted
to you know let the others know that
there was a tool developed for New
Hampshire towns and school districts
that allowed us to plug it in to see if
the final outcome seemed Equitable
seemed Fair seemed appropriate for that
region that rural school at city school
and accounting for those elll students
that are in high numbers in some
districts and non-existent others so
that does
exist um if that's something helpful for
this committee well there's two sides to
this formula remember the left-and side
and the right hand side and the right
hand side has the grant money
extraordinary needs Grant based upon
request property valuation for those
students which qualify f&r
um used to have medium family income and
fiscal capacity disparity Aid which did
I think contribute to making the formula
work fiscal capacity disparity Aid was
taken
out and there be it and and also within
how we but we had a formula that was I
believe had the potential for
working and so if we have an interim
study you know I I I would hope that
that would be part of the you know the
the equation for studying uh yeah yes
thank you I and I agree I think all
these are so interrelated that it would
be hard to study one without studying
all of them um uh have we been on the
outside looking at things from all the
way back from the augen BL formula
through all these different changes it
would be very informative and very
helpful to me to go back and look at
some of these uh previous formulas and
studies thank you you so is it the
feeling of a group right here that inter
room study is probably the best way to
go on this one as well this bill we
haven't talked to
swep Y yep okay so the the last
bill which is
here is the sweat
bill I'll just put my cards on the table
right now I I'm not support of the
excess being having to be returned from
the the particular District that's
raising it I feel that that money ought
to be directed specifically to
educational tasks within that District
whether it be for their own building Aid
or catastrophic Aid or ensuring that
they can have that Spanish teacher in in
the classroom
um that's excess and how much are we
talking on excess is it roughly $30
million yeah 29 point something
yes it it I don't have the exact figure
we get it from Mark I thought it was a
little over call it $30 million
278 I think going after this animal is
just going to cause a real fight and it
sounds to me like in terms of trying to
get this costing of this
budget it's going to take more than that
you know just this the changes I you
know I suggest this morning by doing the
costing here of the adequate education
through that changing it to the 42
560 and with the special ed cost it
comes up to $115 million on top of what
we're spending right
now so it's going to be big money in
terms of unless you can figure out some
magic trick here to keep it where we are
right now and we don't have to go the
property tax or the income tax sales tax
route representing you add it up just a
second before
represent we're in competition
uh first I I want to
uh everyone should know that there are
bills Ways and Means also on this very
same subject uh and we just had our
hearing when was it uh the day before
yesterday on uh two bills one uh is
prime sponsored by rep of
fellows and that one essentially repeals
swept and inserts uh ways of of uh
leading to a soft Landing to
oversimplify what you've done um and
then another bill by
representative can you do
it
uh Bickford representative Bickford has
a bill he's the sole Prime Sole sponsor
the prime sponsor his his
bill um sends the access
to to Dr and into the education trust
fund so it leaves swept intact but uh
diverts the exess to uh to the uh state
level uh we haven't really discussed
those we just had hearings on them
yesterday
or the day before um so those are
sitting out there in addition there's a
bill that I filed uh a couple years ago
that
uh was addressed uh as a retained bill
came to the floor this this year and was
sent to interim study in ways and means
and that bill um accepts the what I
believe is the uh really almost
indisputable legal truth that this is a
state
tax and and sends the excess
swept and all other swept Revenue all at
once to the state level and then um has
an augmented free and reduced price
lunch program that is funded from the
state level as a rebate program uh and
also provides a 3% processed in fee for
uh localities who ra who collect the
money and send it to the state so I
those are out there the the latter one
is actually in
1586 uh the the uh my
bill essentially the same I mean there
are technical changes that need to be
made I have prepared an amendment to uh
to the other swep bill there's so many
numbers here it's hard to keep track U
to
1686 to uh substitute my Approach for
that approach so I'm not here to argue
I'm
not I'm not arguing for any one of these
approaches I'm not sure which way to go
to be truthful but uh they're all out
there uh they all are the product of the
feeling that we've got a legal problem
here with the uh state tax and what to
do with the revenue I believe that uh
the judge was absolutely right in his
conclusion I know Bill ardinger uh
strongly agrees with that who work with
me and the others on various things
including the commission work uh and uh
that one way or the other we've got to
do something about this is the the
decision of the Jud of the suprior court
judge is in appeal so maybe there some
time time to work on it on the other
hand we're collecting an illegal un
potentially unconstitutional tax and uh
some gray uh area there and what uh the
consequences of collecting an
unconstitutional tax are um so that's
just background I'm not sure where I'm
going with this but I just wanted you to
have all of that yeah uh we have two of
the sponsors of 1686 sitting at the
table here representa spillsbury and
representative cascaden um you're a
sponsor on the
bill yeah so representative I'd like to
add a few comments if I
can so as representative Ames just
indicated if you include what's embedded
in 1586 there are four bar four bills to
each in education Ways and Means
carrying three different concepts to
achieve more or less the same thing the
most straightforward is the uh Pickford
bill which which simply restores the
language that was repealed in 2011 to
bring us to the status quo anti take us
back 12 years for 13 years
um I'm a co-sponsor of
1686 um representative Mart Smith's
bill I don't know that it's a clean
solution it's just simply that I agree
that um it needs to be resolved
whether it gets resolved by you know
Committee Action February 15th or goes
to interim study I just think it's an
essential thing that has to be resolved
regardless of the funding
formula and perhaps ahead of the funding
formula um
fundamentally we've got a situation
where a local tax is masquerading as a
state tax and we kind of wanted it to be
both things depending on you know um
where we sit and how we try to justify
things so I completely
understand why a um property relatively
wealthy community would want to
retain the so-called excess amount
that's been collected from their
own uh
taxpayers property
so I uh I actually sympathize with they
ought to be able to keep what they rais
locally when I think of it that way it
just tells me that raising the state's
contribution in any portion whatsoever
off of property tax is the original sin
and that's what we really need to
correct we have folks from Dr here on
this do and you've written a fiscal note
here for for us is there anything you
can add to help us out with this or
understanding the bill the ramifications
impacts
Etc or is
it come on
up uh Keen mang Wong tax policy councel
at the Dr um as so the Dr doesn't really
take any position on the bill um I think
that's kind of expected um what the DI
did was essentially just went through
the bill and uh identified like how it
would work um and any kind of uh
technical issues that we saw and and we
just flaged that on the fiscal note um
and and that is
um so I I wouldn't know if um if
so our comments were basic mainly just
technical in nature um I think the
discussion here is very policy based um
and I I I hesit to to wander into
that that
area Okay are are there any questions
for the Department on the fiscal
note yes represent
luno thank you very much uh Mr chair and
thank you very much for joining us this
morning um there's there obviously
there's been a lot of discussion with
regards to the Statewide property tax
and how it's collected how it's
administered um how some of it is
remitted how some of it's retained and
stuff like that um in part of those
discussions and we had these discussions
during the commission work too there was
suggestion that that the um that the the
state through the Department of Revenue
uh Administration
should collect that tax directly from
every property taxpayer and and I don't
actually believe that that's the right I
think it should be collected locally and
um um because the local um tax clerks
are the ones that are doing property tax
collection and and they're obviously
doing it for the counties and and
remitting it too but I was wondering if
if the Dr were to collect
the um the swept from every property
taxpayer Crown the same what would that
what would that what would that mean for
the
Dr um thank you for the question so um
that would mean that uh so we we will
need to sort of revamp our system
because currently our system is not
built to collect that sum of money so be
it the excess swept or be it the entire
swept that is being calculated
um we would need
certain um measures in place such as we
need to know whether uh would the the
remitting of that money to the Dr is
that going to be done only once a year
versus is it being done every time when
the property bill goes out and then um
is it like a twice a year or quarterly
or once a year so I the we would
anticipate the cleaner option would be
once a year so not withstanding how the
municipalities would to build their uh
send out their property tax how often
they send out their property tax
B the easier option for the Dr to manage
is to receive it only once a year and
then the other consideration is whether
uh would the municipalities be remitting
the total amount that's
calculated whe whether they were
successful in collecting the entire
amount or not so that would be
considered as we we need to think about
that um and and then let's say if um if
the uh if the amount is remitted is not
as what is provided in the
warrant then who goes about in
collecting that outstanding amount um
and then the other thing would be our uh
our Technical Systems uh we probably
need to upgrade our systems to be able
to monitor um the each municipality the
amounts that uh we expecting to receive
uh from the uh from the warrants and
then how much we've been receiving and
then just to keep everything uh keep
track of everything that probably about
uh we anticipate probably about uh I
believe the number was about $300,000
just to update that system
yeah represent
dry thank you thank you for taking my
question I kind of like to change the
subject just a little bit there was some
talk in the last few hearings about ways
that a negative netive tax rate could be
set that were different from this the
swept um
overcharge uh do you remember those I
think it was Mr manganello from the doe
that brought that up but yeah there was
discussion on the negative rates during
the public hearing uh of it but I think
I would like to
invite um my colleague here who might be
well uh Bruce canor uh who might be able
to explain the uh the workings of a
negative rate um my understanding that
negative rate is a function of the math
that's involved um and it it's just a
natural occurrence uh but maybe Bruce
can explain it
better y you're welcome we got to get
two chairs
at we just drag one
up we don't have this big
audience uh good morning Mr chairman and
committee members um for the record my
name is Bruce canu I'm the supervisor of
the municipal Bureau at the Department
of
Revenue that Bureau is tasked with um
helping the commissioner calculate the
property tax rates so uh the team I work
with we are probably some of the most
familiar people in the state with
negative property tax
rates um the representative I think was
referring to the distinction between
how those negative property tax rates
arise in conjunction with the State
education property tax rate and the the
debates and discussions and outcome of
the one court case but it is possible
and there have been
examples of a negative property tax rate
being calculated and used um at the
we'll refer to it as the municipal I
think town I don't know that I can think
of an example of a city so a town it
arises from the same
um type of situation where
non non-property tax revenues exceed the
appropriation amount that's been voted
and that math just drives us to a
negative sum which is then placed in as
the numerator on a fraction that gives
us the tax rate hence we end up with a
negative tax
rate um the math
also has its own natural
implication given the fact that when we
produce a tax rate tax rates and send it
to a
Municipality of course everybody here if
you're a property tax owner knows your
bill is some amount per
thousand but is made up of four
rates so so it's pure mathematics at
that point that if one of those rates is
negative the entire total is that much
less uh the implications of that are
dealt with frankly by the
municipality
and each situation creates its own set
of
ramifications
locally um in fact we are currently
watching those ramifications play out
with one particular
municipality and um there's really no
further role for the department at that
point but that is what happens and it
has happened and I would note as a
historical curiosity and I looked at
this because I'm naturally
curious is that uh this year we saw to
Municipal
rates uh end up being
negative and they both occurred and our
when we produce our list of rates every
week it's
alphabetical and I thought hm I wonder
if this has ever happened before and I
went back to the oldest record that I
can access which is the tax rates of
1975 and I was really I'm quite stunned
the same two
municipalities back then there were only
three rates of
course they had negative Municipal rates
so 48 years I think later um the same
phenomenon occurred again and probably
wasn't the only time in history but it
was just the fact that I looked at the
oldest one go ahead yeah so thank you
that just makes me ask if the bills Pro
prohibition on the Dr from setting
negative local and County tax rates on
real property kind of steps into
territory that doesn't have to do with
education
taxes
um specifically I mean if that bill was
law I believe the bureau would stop the
rate at zero it wasn't would not go
negative and it would apply and I think
there was a question and it may have
been in in
uh the other hearing as to whether or
not the agency would see the word
local um as meaning Municipal um I can't
speak with definitively for the agency
I'm sure that they the the attorney and
the commissioner and as well would want
to weigh in it seems for me the most
natural initial reading of the the law
that all the rates would be subject to
the same you know prohibition it's not
quite clear
but representative cascaden thank you uh
thank you for taking my question so I'm
interpreting now your explanation that
it the negative tax rate did not only
apply to unincorporated
locations there are
corporated or Incorporated yes
municipalities yes there are oh okay
that was that's a revelation to me I
always thought it was unincorporate at
locations that work that negative
certainly the the one court case
highlighted the fact because of the
nature of the unincorporated being so
small and in some cases having
almost no people involved hence no
pupils to create a school district an
act an active School District you you'd
see you see it much more often there and
then and the nature of that case
involved the local school rate and it's
and the swep so
are there any other questions of the
Dr it's an interesting topic yes sir it
is really is it ought to stop at
zero thank you very much
um yeah yeah so what we're going to do
is we're going to take a break right now
uh it's right at 12 o'clock and there's
no heat in this room as you know we'd
have no hea in the building and there's
a pipe broken somewhere so uh we're
going to take a moment to warm our hands
up have a little lunch and we'll come
back at
1:00 yep thank you very
much
oh I don't think we need you back here I
think you're off to
hook
when you're ready to go ahead we are
kind of limited on time in the afternoon
here uh some of us have a 2 o'clock
appointment
and I got a 4:30 doctor's appointment in
Le they check my blood to make sure the
in the thinner is where it's
supposed to
be the other day was like 1.6 oh you
gotta be about 2.0 and I
said Fray next
Friday it's in the calendar yeah
yep yeah yeah we'll hopefully have a
little bit more info back on the CATE
cat categories for special ed we may
have some actual costs I don't know we
we'll find
out welcome Mark
uh you got it's fun yeah uh Mark M
Department of Education Bureau of school
Finance um so you do have um uh two
packets in front of you um hopefully you
don't get them mixed around the first
packet is walking through um or both
packets what this is doing is this is
1586 but not as introduced uh
representative luno and I um uh played
around with a couple different variables
there's a lot of variables that can be
played around in this uh formula uh 1586
as as introduced by representative luno
um so some of the variables that uh were
discussed was changing the universal Aid
amount and so um I think we talked about
this a little bit last week um plugging
in that conal number the minimum base
Aid that conal uh said was $7,000 uh
that's the Superior Court decision um
7,356 so plugging that number in there
um that was one change that made as
introduced it was
6,500 um another change that
representative luno uh discussed with me
was um the minimum contribution amount
um um making that not $5 but I believe
it's you'll see it on the second
spreadsheet when we get there but it's
going to be
$425 we can discuss how that works
mechanically through the formula um
another change from what was introduced
is is um the phase in uh which we'll
talk about um instead of being 70% and
phasing in over 10 years representative
Luna was interested in um potentially
pursuing phasing in in over 5 years and
having an 80% um percentage phase in so
basically that was the scenario I ran
you have two packets the the money is on
the backs side so if you can just be
patient um with the two towns
highlighted Allenstown and Alton that
one has the dollar amounts but if we can
just first walk through the weights um I
should think think we should be able to
go through this relatively quickly um
but I'll I'll walk through how the
formula the weights of the formula works
first so just like any other adequacy
spreadsheet this is by municipality so
you can see the town by Town um so in um
at the top there it's column A that's
just admr um and so that is admr um as
we estimated it to be for school year
24 uh so I plugged in that number um and
an admr is weighted at one so no weight
well really just a standard weight it's
weighted at one so aworth has 94 admr so
for this formula we are waiting them at
one um fnr um is uh for aworth we have
32.242262
students weighted at 1.49 turns into 48
students uh 48 weights
really sped is being weighted at 4.29 I
know you've been discussing this um so
slow down just a second special
education ADM you have 4.29 got it you
said 48
weights sorry I'm following aworth we're
doing aworth let me slow down um aworth
94 admr is weighted one is 94 that's
column B column C is fnr of aworth of
32.242262
process um English language Learners
there's zero within aworth there's one
within Alexandria so one English
language learner is weighted at
2.2 so we are now for Alexandria they
have a weight of 2.2 in their in their
column there in column
H so the first part of this formula is
working with these kind of Weights as
we're used to seeing them in regular Uh
current law adequacy um so in column I
we're tallying those all up so um for
aworth we tally up the 94 weights the 48
weights the 85.8 weights and we get
227.04
weights and so that's somewhat
straightforward pretty similar to
current adequacy um as far as telling up
the weights the weights are different
than how we do it in adequacy but it's
uh somewhat
similar so we're still in the process of
figuring out the weights for each
municipality the next one is a little
more comp complicated it's buckets ra I
have described as buckets relative to
school district size so if you are under
200 um where you're going to receive a
particular weight if you are between
2011 and 600 you're going to receive a
weight um if you're between 601 to 12200
in school district size you're going to
receive a weight and aworth which is
part of the Fall Mountain School
District has an admr student population
between 121 and 2,000 so I'm just coding
them as they're going to receive however
many students they have in that weight
that's going to be the weight they're
categorized um if we go down to Albany
Alban is a very small school district
they have under 200 um actually they're
nonp product Cooperative so I can tell
you what their adars it's it's uh 68.4
or
68.4 so they have under 200 in their
school district of Albany so they're
going to be bucketed as under 200 um so
first we're bucketing where these School
school districts uh are where they kind
of live as far as size is concerned
where it gets a little unique is if you
scroll down to Amherst which is location
code number 17 it's a few lines down um
you'll see that
3268 and the uniqueness with uniqueness
with that is Amherst is a town that Bel
has two school districts so um I'm just
a portioning out what is Amherst the k
through eight and then what is Sagan
which is the 9 through 12 and so um some
of Amherst is part of the it's it's
single District Etc and some of it's a
split Cooperative um so that was kind of
a just sort of a uniqueness as far as
how that
applies but I'm just bucketing where
these school districts are the next
process is adding in the
weights so if we look back at
aworth um I'm not showing you all the
work there's a lot of math behind this
and unhiding of a bunch of ex uh columns
would show this math but I'm just trying
to present a highle um and not bore you
with too much math but aworth here um
essentially what I did with aworth is
it's part of Fall Mountain Fall Mountain
under HB uh
1586 they have basically what you do is
you do the negative so man the fractions
don't really show up really well in this
the spreadsheet but it's negative uh I
believe point 0
point
0049 times the ADM of aworth so that's
times the
4 um
uh with starting off with an intercept
of around one so basically we're just
adding a negative a very small negative
amount because it's a very small number
here to that one ADM starting point so
they're not being really punished that
much they're being kind of benef uh well
yeah they're basically just getting a
weight of of one there actually no
they're basically having their weight
just disappear um yeah they're getting a
weight of one that's how I'm seeing that
oh no no no yeah weight of one is uh
sorry then I'm going to times it by
their students now now I can understand
my own spreadsheet um they're they're
getting 096 is what I'm going to Times
by The a worth number of 94 so they're
going to get 96% of those 94 that's
their weight and it turns out to be 90.4
2 so it's a little technical there
there's a lot of sort of calculations
happening in the
background um Albany um is a small
school district so they're going to have
a more advantageous weight um their
weight ends up being
1.3 and I do that 1.3 times the 68 and I
get 89.4 one weights so we talked a
little bit about this last week where
this part of the formula uh in 1586
mostly benefits small school districts
like Albany um so Albany is getting um
1.31 weights for each student they have
um
moving
forward
yep um so the places like uh am that
have two
numbers yes how do you how do you do
that let's see how I did that I think I
portioned it out but let me you
did yep so 32% yeah so
I 32%
is 32% of those students belong to the
single District
and they were credited as
um uh credited as the 601 to 1200 and
then 30 and then 68% belonged to the um
Cooperative I believe and they were
credited as
the9 weight
measurement so I'd have to get into the
details of how I calculated it but I'd
have to go into my spreadsheet but I a
portioned it out based on so like 0.12
times the numbers in that range and then
9 and then add those together yeah I
took I I I took basically I took the 30
Amherst has 1700 or 1,00 students but
32% of them um so not all 1,800 of them
are going to fall in the 601 bucket so
basically I take am H and split it out
and then I have to combin it back
together um but I had to put them in two
different buckets because you end up
with one number at the end yes okay so I
split them out for a second and then put
them back together okay
um so if you tally up the district
weights there um you'll see just staying
on aworth aworth has
9.42 um Statewide that's 41 uh, weights
um we have another wave of waiting and
it's based on grade level so Statewide
we have
36,000 um six and eth graders so six and
eighth graders were given a weight of
1.42 so aworth has I don't have the raw
data here but they have under 26 um I
don't have to do the math but uh
whatever 1.4 * x uh equals 26 x is the
number of six and eighth graders they
have I don't I don't know have that
number off the top of my head but I've
I've added the weights there I've taken
all these six and eighth graders within
aworth and I've multiplied that number
by 1.42 and I got
26 for GR 9 and 12 I did the same
process um so aworth likely has around
20ish um 9 and 12 grade graders and so
when I take that number that raw number
which is probably around 20 and I
multiply it by 042 I get 11 so that's
how we're dealing with the grade level
weights and so at this part of the
formula we're done with the weights we
first we tally them all up for a the
total number of Weights ends up being
265.0 4 so that includes their sort of
normal admr student counts which is 94
plus all these different categories that
they get little they get add-ons for um
like having a um like being a school
district of a particular size like
having grade level students at a
particular grade um like having students
that are sped or fnr and so when we
tally that up we get
265.0
4 the way this and representative luno
can explain this more in more detail but
I'll just sort of summarize at a high
level the concept that he's explained to
um this committee and other committees
before is essentially he's tallying up
all these numbers and
uh uh the way it's my understanding is
that he's trying to get to a number that
equals something approximate to the
total State cost of Education minus
federal revenue is that a correct
interpretation um so where we end up
with these weights and with this metric
if I take the 400
32,000 weights and I times it by
7,356 and that was a number that was
plugged in um and it's based on the
conval decision or uh uh number provided
so if I tally up those
432,000 uh weights and I multiply by
7,356 I get around 3.2 billion and so um
as representative luno talks about his
intent his intent was for that number to
represent approximately the state total
share of Revenue that goes to school
districts minus Federal um so in we're
generally in that ballpark there um you
know give or take you know dozens of
millions but um we're it's a it's a
large number 3.2
billion can the the reason it's in that
ballpark isn't because it was finger and
the wind you know maybe we'll get close
or something like that it's because of
the work that the uh that the commission
did in analyzing doe 25 data from all of
the school districts knowing what that
total cost is is knowing how those costs
can be attributed to these different um
differentiated Aid factors so there's
there's there's no surprise that it
comes within the ballpark yep and that's
yeah so a lot of these weights and how
these weights were determined represent
luno can speak to them because they deal
with a 2020 commission report and the
report can um obviously walk you through
them as well excuse me one more time um
is that number 3.2 billion is that
before the federal money is taken out or
after the after okay so do you know that
number off the top of my head um I know
it's in the ballpark I don't know um I
don't have it off the top of my head
Federal no the federal number that you
subtracted 200 it's it's around um it's
around 3 I think the number for fiscal
year 23 I believe it's 3.8 billion and
we have about 400 million in federal
revenue so I think it's around 3.4
billion so a little bit more than 3.2
okay thank you just a quick uh every
time that ADM is referenced it's an R
not an a uh yes thanks for this formula
yes so we we have that um Universal
based cost times the weights and we get
that number which totals up Statewide to
3.2
billion the next column column W is
there's two things that are applied to
that number in 1586 um it's one of them
is called an efficiency Factor so it it
it's that immediately applies a 95%
number to it so it takes 5% out of it
um and then there's something called a
transition percentage phase in and so as
representative luno and I discussed he
wanted to see what the numbers looked
like with that at 80% as introduced it's
at 70% so when you take 95% off that 3.2
billion or sorry 5% off it and then you
take 20% off it you get a number that's
smaller than 3.2 billion you get 2.4
billion and so um that transition phase
in or transition percentage
as uh described in the concept of 1586
is going to be 80% one year and then the
next year it's going to grow and then
grow and then grow until you have 100%
which would actually only be 95% because
of the efficiency Factor um but that is
how uh 1586 1586 is const constructed so
that you would slowly phase into the
full 3.2
billion so that is the weight side if
everyone is okay we can move on to the
second one which gets more into the
money so we'll we'll stay in the world
of aworth uh for now just because it's
the easy one to uh at the top of the
line but um I did highlight Allenstown
and Alton because I kind of wanted to
walk through those two scenarios of um
uh a school district that's going to
receive more money through this uh uh
Bill and then um a school school
district that's going to not receive
money money uh through this bill
um so column W is just that's the what
the last column we just ended on that
2.4 billion Statewide that is the um
Foundation opportunity budget with the
95% efficiency Factor applied and the
80% transition percentage phase in
applied um so for aworth this is
essentially what the concept of their
Foundation opportunity budget um The
Benchmark that aworth needs to have a
foundation opportunity budget as defined
in the bill is 1.48 5 million so that's
the Benchmark similar to the cost of
inadequate education that is The
Benchmark that needs to be achieved um
uh in in this bill but before the state
cuts them a check for 1.5 million uh it
is going to look at what their minimum
local contribution is and so in column X
we have the equalized valuation that is
the property values um including
utilities that's
equalized um so we are going to apply uh
um a
$425 per thousand tax rate to that
number so for aworth they have $164
million in property value on an
equalized
basis if we apply a $425 tax rate to
that or other also known as 43 uh 43% of
their property or percentage um that
raises 600
97,000 so to achieve their Foundation
opportunity budget which is 1. 485
million they're going to do a minimum
contribution of 697
th000 so that is their minimum
contribution uh uh in column Z there
it's a it's a lesser less of the two uh
uh column that I had in there um so 6
697 is the lesser of of the two it's
less it's um less than their Foundation
opportunity budget um so their state
Opportunity Grant is going to be
whatever the difference is between their
minimum contribution and the foundation
opportunity budget so they need
$787,000 plus their minimum contribution
to get them up to the 1.48 five million
so their state Opportunity Grant um in
1586 is going to be 787 th000
um that's the core mechanics of the bill
but there's more that goes on there's a
transition Grant Mark Mr chair yeah so
so the the three columns that Mark just
U just highlighted are probably the most
important ones in here it's column W
which is the foundation opportunity
budget which was that all those weight
calculations that that come up with that
and then the um the minimum local
contribution in Z which is the first
dollars toward WS that Foundation
opportunity budget so rather than State
dollars being the first dollars towards
the budget it's local dollars which are
the first dollars to the budget and then
column AA which is the state Opportunity
Grant that get you using State money to
hit if you haven't been able to hit your
foundation opportunity budget with your
local money then the state comes in and
that's um that's column AA thank you
thanks thanks for walking through that
um so yeah as we are with column AA the
state Opportunity Grant um there's also
a hold harmless provision and I'm going
to go down one row to Albany because for
Albany a hold harmless comes into play
and so Albany the state Opportunity
Grant is expected to be
$468,000 in in sort of State cash a
check from the state um because their
minimum contribution is 814k and their
opportunity budget is 1.3 million so um
right now at this moment in the formula
they're expected to get 468k
um in a funding from the
state but if we look at their fiscal
year 25 total education grant um that
includes the hold harmless formula
that's in current law but does not
include swept the state cash they
received was
521k and so um they are held harmless
and so in order to hold them harmless
the next column over is the 53k they
need
$53,000 added to that 4 60 AK to bring
them up to what they were receiving
under current law and so um the way
these metrics were applied um the
transition Grant is is actually a pretty
small dollar amount um it's six around
$7 million Statewide um so very few
communities need that transition Grant
um for the factors added into here um
but Albany appears to be one of
them um but yeah most communities are
not uh receiving that transition
Grant uh so moving forward um their new
state grant that does not include swept
and we're going to get to swept in a
second um it's their Opportunity Grant
and their transition grant that is going
to be 1.2 uh billion
Statewide um where things get a little
technical is we need to compare this if
I'm going to compare 1586 to current law
I need to factor in swept so in
1586 um
swept the dollar amount the amount
raised stays uh what it is under current
law it's
363 um or whatever it takes to get to
363 million it's 364 million um for
fiscal year 25 um so it's the 364
million um right there
except 3% of it is going to retain
locally under 1586 um so that can go
straight from the tax collector actually
stays with the tax collector stays with
the municipality is my understanding
um and 97% of it is going to be remitted
to the state so um just to go through
aworth acworth's total swept is
$194,000 they are going to keep
$5,800 and then I don't have a
calculator in front of me but um uh the
rest of it approximately 189,000 is
going to go remitted to the
state um so in order to and I could have
probably been a little bit better with
my descriptions here
but column AG is telling you what 1586
does for your community um as proposed
and as discussed with the representative
luno um for aworth it's
793 th000 and the reason why it's higher
than that 787 th000 that we calculated
back in column ad uh is because I'm
adding the amount to they get to R keep
and retain under
1586 um uh and it's $5,000 for $5,800
plus the
$787 gets the total amount that aworth
is essentially keeping so that's 793
th000 um that is the AG column for
aworth um under current law they receive
682k um and that includes swept because
all of swep in under current law is
retained locally so they receive every
swept dollar um they raise under 1586
they only received 133% so um um just so
and I'm going to get into the Alton is
going to help explain the difference
between how sweps going to work under
this new bill uh under this uh proposed
bill um
682 um is what they received for swept
and adequacy grants under under current
law and so what the difference is is
under 1586 and all these metrics put in
there um aworth would receive a addition
additional funding of
110k um so that's how it works for
aworth and
so I'm going to go through the Allen's
how are we doing a time we got 30
minutes I'm going to go through the
Allenstown example and the AL Alton
example and that's going to help explain
um a little bit more of how this funding
is working um I think uh representative
America had a question about um where is
this money coming from so this proposal
as in front of you 200 mil 2011 million
is um above and beyond what you
currently are paying in education so
that would require a funding source that
is not well as proposed in here that
would essentially require education
trust fund dollars however you may get
them
um yeah yeah so so in part um under this
proposal um 200 million would need to be
funded through some Source not already
identified in The
Proposal um I'm going to explain how
some of the swept dollars is going to
help uh uh support this bill as proposed
1586 and I think the example for that is
Alton um so Allenstown and I highlighted
Allenstown and Alton so we're going to
we're going to switch between the two
Allenstown is a community that's
receiving more money Alton is a
community that is going to receive less
money under this proposal so for
Allenstown and
Alton uh their proposed budget is their
Foundation opportunity budget is around
um they're pretty similar actually um
8.4 million and for Alton it's 8 7
million so that's the Benchmark that
needs to be hit um under
1586 then we look at their property
values so Allenstown has um 53 31
million as a property tax base so when
you apply the
$425 tax to that tax base it brings in
$2.2
million um $2.2 million does not take
them all the way to the 8.4 million so
if you skip over to column W uh
daa um uh they need a state check of 6.2
million to bring them up to the 8.4
million so that's how it's going to work
for Allenstown uh in 1586 for Alton
their Benchmark they're kind of the
newly defined cost of in adequate
education essentially um the foundation
opportunity budget is 8.7
million their property values are 3.5
billion so the $425 rate applied to that
tax uh base brings in $15 million almost
so um Alton has a minimum contribution
that exceeds the foundation opportunity
budget so their minimum contribution um
uh essentially is it only needs to be
8.7 million to hit the foundation
opportunity budget um so they don't need
to raise as much um uh as the as the as
the 4.2 4.25 number
so their state check is $0 because their
minimum contribution covers um the
foundation opportunity budget so Al
Alton will receive um uh 0 Allenstown
would receive $6.2 million um so that's
how that's working now I'm going to jump
back to that swept column um if you can
look at column AA and you can look at um
Allenstown and
Alton um under current law Allenstown
swept is
636k and they retain all of that funding
um under current law Alton swept is 4.2
million and they retain all of that
funding um but under 1586 what would
happen is Allenstown would keep $19,000
of that swept which is 3% and Alton
would keep
127,000 so essentially I don't have the
math here but um um
uh you know 4.1 million uh in swept from
Alton would be going to the state um so
the way that's working out mechanically
is under
1586 they are Alton is receiving 127k in
retained uh retained swept um but under
current law they keep their entire swept
so the way that's working out is that um
under current law 1586 as proposed
compared to current law they are having
a decrease in school funding by 4.1
million so to describe how it's being
paid
for 200 million would need to come from
a re Revenue Source not identified in
1586 but
essentially
97% of swept is is going or going to the
state and so for um some of that funding
is also coming from a town like Alton in
a sense that um they're receiving 4.1
million less State funding because the
swept is remitted to the state so that's
also one of the funding source that's
how swept works as a funding source in
1586 because um swept is now going to
the state which means you're not uh
guaranteed all of it you're only
guaranteed um you're only guaranteed the
variance between your opportunity budget
and your minimum contribution which for
Alton is 0 so that's and you're
guaranteed the 3% swept retain so I
don't know if I did a good job
explaining that it's a little tricky um
if we need to go through that again uh
um let me know or if there's any
questions on
that so MB sends back $7
million M bro yep we can uh yeah sorry
this is not
uh
so so on on that Rick and
and if I can just use the alt one since
it's highlighted and right on the is
outside as mka no no no yeah similar
type of thing but but but at the same
time they don't need to be kicking in
the whole four and a quarter to meet
$425 to meet their Foundation
opportunity budget and similar to in
Alton Alton can probably get to their
Foundation opportunity budget with about
$3 and um and then yeah they're losing
the swept and that's a122 so that gets
them to about 4 and a quarter which is
still less than most towns like or
cities like conquered or hopkington are
going to be paying in combination
between the
$425 local contribution minimum
contribution and the uh the122 uh State
Property Tax so so the the the whole
idea here though is rather than towns
some towns spending 15 20 $25 per
thousand to meet their um their local
school budgets uh in in in in this in
the the um the the plan here and
obviously these are a lot of dials that
can be can be turned um
$425 plus
a122 essentially constitutes the um the
max um uh property tax for any um
municipality
so sure I heard that correctly the
maximum would be five plus 1.22 ma the
um the the combination of the local
minimum the
$425 plus a122 would be the most that
you have to put towards um sure and the
1.22 is a given and the five is a cap uh
well it's not a five it's the
4.25 and and the and this is one of the
things I think we need to to definitely
work out in the study is rather than
having a a fixed dollar amount have that
float based on fiscal policy on what the
state share should be and uh because
when when we have such dramatic
increases in property valuations as we
have over the last three years Statewide
property valuations went from 220
billion to 340 billion that all of a
sudden a $5 per thousand is way you know
way out of out of whack so so we'd want
to probably most likely float that rate
um onto onto what the um the state
obligation would be from a fiscal policy
sto just to clarify uh uh uh the
for for the the
$425 is it's a minimum contribution so
it's it's how much money um it's your
minimum contribution to hit the
foundation opportunity budget some
communities might want to go uh above
and beyond the foundation opportunity
budget and therefore they would have to
raise more than $4 20 uh they depends on
the community um depends on how much
State money you receive um but some
communities might have to have a tax
higher than $425 cents if they want to
go above and beyond the foundation
opportunity budget and there's no other
Revenue Source available that's entirely
based on local decisions that's not
based but it's but it's local decisions
that for many towns aren't made in the
town they're made in the Regional School
District subject
to your Cooperative would be um
Cooperative is a different yeah it's all
based on how the Cooperative would flow
through and how it impact taxes that's
right um another thing uh just to
understand um representative Luna was
talking about where to Peg a doll where
to Peg the um uh minimum contribution
rate um how to get it to float um uh
probably some more work uh the study
committee that's a a good suggestion for
the study committee to look at um just
so you guys have a little context about
uh some of the variables that
representative luno and I uh were
discussing
was minimum contribution whatever you
said that to is going to obviously
impact this formula greatly so um you
could run scenarios I ran just a couple
scenarios for representative luno um you
could set it at $3 if you set it at $3
that's a low lower minimum contribution
which means the state needs to spend
more money um you could set it a higher
number so if you sent it at $5 then the
state needs to pay less money um so
that's one dial you can uh uh move
around and and see you know how much
money you have or uh how much money you
can spend um that's going to impact the
total State spend um and that's going to
impact this formula um the other uh
metric that representative Luna and I
were moving around with um is the
percentage transition phase in um like I
said it was 70% as int roduced about 80%
in this proposal um the higher you make
that percentage the more you phase in
the more the higher the opportunity
budget means which potentially means the
more State money that needs to go out
for districts to hit that or for
municipalities to hit that Benchmark um
so that's one factor um that could
change the the the price tag and the
distribution here um was that the two
main those are the two main factors I
think we looked at um I I I think you're
right Mark and and and I I think the the
um scenario that Mark has put together
here uh is is really it's not to it's
not to settle on um what the local
minimum contribution is or anything like
that but it's really to to Really sort
of illustrate how how a different um
costing and funding structure with
similar amounts of State dollars so I
know this is 200 million more than than
the current um um State funding but but
the other two scenarios that we we're
taking a look at are 800 million more
and then another 600 million more than
that so $ 1.4 billion more and and you
can see what this does for the the most
some of the most um economically
challenged communities around our state
or or or challenged with um with with
with with with different um um
uh situations in their in their District
such as Manchester such as Rochester
such as Claremont and Berlin and um and
so so it's really here to illustrate we
could we could go we could
make adjustments to the current model in
the tune of $1.4 billion and see that it
doesn't do that much for Berlin or
Claremont or Manchester or make
adjustments more in the 200 million or
maybe even less and see what that does
for for Berlin Claremont Manchester and
others
thanks yes ripson
Ames I think it's important to keep in
mind that this is a a spreadsheet that
shows uh getting to
70% of the
um opportunity budget not
100% And
um 80% sorry it it uh it's 80% of what
is going to cost and um cost and then
contributions vary but uh there's a big
difference there and I think it's going
to be important at some point soon to
see where we're going to get to at
100% uh it's a big difference and we
need to know uh the good and the bad and
hard of all
that are there any projections that you
mentioned 21 million right now right
what are you projecting five years
hence so five years hence it would go up
to in in column W It Go from 80% to
100% it depends on how the yeah it
depends on the variable so um if you do
80% up to 100%
and you assume zero growth in property
value then I I have to number run the
numbers to just know it's a lot so but
if you it depends on how it depend on
how
you in theory if the foundation
opportunity phas in grows at the same
rate as property values then the overall
net uh cost to the state would be kind
of neutral because for every dollar
you're growing you're also growing the
minimum contribution and those would
wash each other out now it's going to
get obviously messy with a spreadsheet
town by Town um because not every
property growth is not uniformly growing
everywhere but generally if that's
generally the average of What would
happening it would wash it out to some
extent um but that's all depends on how
you
design how you Peg the minimum
contribution and then how you phase in
um uh how you phase in the foundation
opportunity budget but you could
probably design a model that
approximately washes out um I don't know
I don't know if I can do that but you
could study it and see if you can see if
you can build that model um I think it's
I think it's doable if you study
it um but you would be assuming property
you're making assumptions about property
growth which is very hard to do and I
don't like doing that
so and and and I and I think that's one
of the most challenging things about our
current form current formula and and
this one too is property valuation and I
think Manchester is another good example
here which is a year ago during the
budget process we had uh predicted we we
had expected that Manchester was going
to receive and I don't remember the
numbers off the top my head in terms of
the extraordinary needs Grant but
because of the increase in property
valuations that Grant was reduced
significantly and uh it was just not
something that I think could have been
was was predicted back at the time the
budget work was
done there other questions yes go ahead
so just quick
numbers here I wrote down the
opportunity budget for each of the five
towns that comprise Fall Mountain School
District and they aggregate 21,
210,000 so the combination of the
minimum and the state
Grant the opportunity budget is
21.21%
so this
is only
60% of what would be required to
maintain current spending so that extra
40% is effectively what the the five
towns would have to come together and
decide whether to further charge the
property tax right back to what we said
the other day the property tax in this
formula is bearing three layers the
minimum the swept in the increment and
it's going to be very
high right and and um and so so there's
a couple of things on that uh we started
with 80% not 100% so that would
obviously get it get it um much closer
to uh to to current get it from 80 to 95
did I understand yeah 80 to 95 99 that's
the the efficiency reduction and uh and
those things could be modeled um uh
along with looking at um the um the the
local minimum contribution could be uh
could be modeled up a little bit to try
to keep the uh the state share at I I
think what were we aiming at dick a a
42%
fiscal um policy for the state share and
uh but I you know I I think
Mark this this hopefully gives us a lot
think about um certainly Visa V some of
the other bills that have that have
looked at at um at changes too and and
um and what do how how can State money
be used best to move the needle to
really you know be directed towards
towards the communities that need it
most and so I I I hear what you're
saying I don't
think this is not being suggested as a
landing uh place it's being suggested as
a as a a spot to start a
discussion well I think it's extremely
interesting I'm still absorbing a lot
I'm I'm going to go back you know look
at the equalized value and just make a u
a quick estimate for what I think that
would involve to maintain current
funding and I can tell you next
Friday
um hopkington has the honor of having
the highest mill rate currently in the
state and charlestown's number two so we
are compatriots here
um and uh you know we're everything is
so skewed in terms of uh property
valuations one of the things I'm trying
to figure out is where the house bill
this
spring included fiscal capacity
disparity Aid and the ultimate hb2
Senate version didn't
it uh it made a dramatic difference for
property poor
towns so I'm going to be looking at
1586 and asking how does that compare to
the combination of fiscal capacity
disparity aid augmenting adequacy aid
which you know because I think that's
still an option when we'd have to
persuade the Senate to go along right
but but the way that the funding came
out of uh the house this spring I
thought at least from the perspective of
my constituents was a a very good
arrangement I'm not sure yet how this
compares to that
combination definitely better than
adequacy Aid by itself but the formula
here it takes a lot into account in
terms of you know special needs free and
reduced it's reading level uh it takes a
lot into account in terms of a school
size um it doesn't take a lot into
account
in terms of adjusting for equalized
valuation and property poor communities
so that component I think is
deemphasized here and they're of course
they're all competing with each other I
get it but yeah yeah with with the with
the exception that that you know I'd say
a couple things I I and I agree with you
on the fiscal capacity disparity Aid and
that was really I think the only way
that we could approach that given our
current um the the the funding formula
that we've got to work with because this
one us uses the local minimum
contribution as the first thing that's
essentially a fiscal capacity disparity
because you're you're carving into your
foundation to a degree to a degree to a
degree um but but one of the things that
that you won't find on this although
we've got a little bit of it uh for the
the tax transition grants is there's no
hold harmless there's no stabilization
there's no right hand side of the
formula the whole idea is that this is a
Formula that that is designed to to um
to work maybe not with the numbers the
way the way the dials are turned right
now but um but it's it's essentially
designed to be to to to be fair funding
for all of our school
districts well that when we when you
look at that previous formula when I
keep hearkening back too that 2008
version we did have fiscal capacity
disparity Aid built upon those several
conditions and we also had within the
differentiated Aid which is a part of
adequacy the builtin f&r
allocations uh which which were even
double for her District uh in terms of a
double of the base and through that
means I think that formula is able to
I'd like to be able to see how that
original formula would look in terms of
today yeah that's that's worth doing and
and and and do this
comparison um I I just the fiscal
capacity disparity Aid you talk about is
extremely important for those poorer
communities and and that's why we worked
for 1680 to get that in there and we did
in the house but you know we got messed
around with on the other side of the
wall and and so
yeah well i' like to cander I voted
against hb2 because of fact that there
was no of conference and that was
dropped down there may have been some
other reasons but that was the primary
one so somewhere along the way would it
t would it be a real huge job to put
together a spreadsheet dealing with the
old
formula it would take me to some not
algen I'm talking about esterbrook yeah
2008 um I'd have to go through
representative fellow's old spreadsheets
I believe um so I'd have to see hold on
a sec this representative fellos and I
had a little discussion before lunch she
left a whole book over there regarding
the old formula somewhere on Pleasant
Street um yeah I I haven't studied the
uh well um if it's Pleasant Street we
moved it hopefully they didn't throw it
away they they hopefully got moved to 25
Hall Street um yeah have to it' be a
matter of uh me studying the old
formulas and seeing if I can modernize
it um um but that yeah I mean I I I can
running a fisical capacity disparity Aid
formula um as I currently understand it
which was enacted in 2021 for a onetime
uh uh Aid amount um uh doesn't seem
doesn't seem that challenging um unless
there's a a a anomaly or quirkiness to
the 2008 Formula um I think the major
changes is the data sets um there was a
two-year lag on the data um but I mean I
could run analysis on fiscal capacity
disparity a I can run analysis on um I
think the old formula might have had
fiscal clip I'm not sure if it did it
did and that would we certainly want to
change that those Cliffs were horrible
when you were dropping down to the next
cortile or
next you
know we address
that well that that was exactly right we
did reference that or do that in 2021 uh
state law had the fnr percentage uh
without fiscal cliffs it had fiscal
capacity disparity Aid with no fiscal
cliffs so you've enacted uh those
funding Vehicles whether I think what
your question is whether basically what
is the median evpp of 2008 and did you
did you hit that Target in 2021 I mean
you I know I was involved in some of
that work with the LBA but um basically
I think you would you I don't know what
I don't know what the the target was or
the what it looked like in 2008 I don't
know if you hit that median evpp or if
you you are below or under under it and
how you distributed Aid um but I could
do some research into that and see it
could be just be a really aggressive
fiscal capacity disparity Aid I don't
know I'd have to look at the data yeah
you'd have to look at it because if you
fell below the average there's a lot of
little qualifiers to receive that Aid in
that formula oh oh you're right okay so
the old formula had if you are I did it
use Employment Security is that there
was some there's
some
[Music]
Yeah medium family income so yeah and
then you also use property
valuation so that it would be harder I'm
not familiar with that data um I don't
know okay US
Census but the title one
data
no okay 10
years I've got an old sheet at the house
off to look at that with the
instructions
okay uh yeah I've been I've been digging
through some old old old files from uh
2008 but uh um I could I could I could
see what the mechanism was but yeah I
believe that's right there was uh if
your family income percentage or or
poverty percentage is X then these
grants aren't applying to you so that's
an easy obviously an easy thing to plug
into Excel the harder part is does that
data still exist is it in a modern
format that matches how it was used in
2008 um and I'm not familiar with it so
I can't really can't really tell you i'
have to familiarize myself with it well
something we could look at I think it'd
be really great to be able to to do some
comparison yep I can look into that
thank
you we're right at four or three minutes
of according to that time zone there um
any further discussions or questions of
Mark if not we want to thank you Mark
for coming down this is a lot of work
and we appreciate what you put the time
in and it's a lot I'm looking at a lot
of confusion in front of me and I'll
have to go through this thing and and
and and study a little bit more but
thank you very much take a few deep
breaths deep some breaths yes drink a
couple coffee and do it tough stuff for
Friday afternoon pardon me tough stuff
for Friday afternoon absolutely
absolutely represent yes it is so we
have a meeting schedule for next Friday
I think it should be in the calendar I
haven't looked at the calendar just came
out the other night it's there good for
10 o'clock same time uh can we use your
room again please and it'll be in this
room thank
you it's yeah it's well yes they've got
it turned on now and it there was
something in it like air air something
wrong with it and it was blocking it
they had to bleed the pipes yeah they
had to bleed so so if it's like that put
your hand on it then run up and find
Darren say
hey